Imatra des allures de ville fantôme
destination prisée des Russes ils ne
viennent plus profiter des commerces et
de la nature la Finlande a suspendu les
visades tourisme c'est la fin des
affaires pour les régions frontalières
au poste de valima certains russes
traversent encore mais au compte-goutte
ils ont un visa de travail ou la double
nationalité
ce but est arrivé de Saint-Pétersbourg
avec une trentaine de passagers
je ne les avais pas vu depuis 7 ans donc
on allait jusqu'au cas où les règles
changent vous savez tout va bien en
Russie il n'y a pas de problème
[Musique]
les gens n'ont pas le temps de penser
tout le temps à ce qu'il se passe dans
le monde ou à la politique
rien n'a vraiment changé dans les
grandes villes comme Saint-Pétersbourg
ou Moscou même s'il y a des sanctions
internationales on a des produits de
remplacement donc en fait c'est la même
chose
la circulation à la frontière a baissé
de 85% et chaque véhicule est inspecté
l'Union européenne adoptée des sanctions
fortes contre la Russie pas question de
laisser passer des marchandises
interdites
de nombreux douaniers qui vérifiaient
avant les importations s'occupent
désormais de surveiller les exportations
vers la Russie
depuis le déclenchement de la guerre on
a détecté 25000 cassiuspects
quand il s'agit de personnes
individuelles c'est presque toujours des
produits de luxe des habits ou des
produits high-tech quand il s'agit de
transport commercial c'est presque
toujours de la technologie des machines
ou des pièces détachées pour véhicules
en dehors du transport de marchandises
il y a la question de l'entrée illégale
de personnes sur son territoire la
Finlande cherche à protéger sa frontière
avec ce fameux projet pilote d'immatra
une barrière longue de 3 km avec des
barbelés des caméras dont la
construction prendra fin d'ici cet été
ensuite Helsinki prévoit de construire
d'autres tronçons dans les zones les
plus à risque de sa frontière longue de
1300 km avec la Russie